do you ever look back at the rich gang
era and realize how historical like the
history y'all kind of were like you were
saying earlier sometimes you live in
memories you don't know how important
those memories are because you're in the
middle of it oh yeah the rich gang [ __ ]
just from a Fan's perspective just
looking back at like wow
I mean everybody who was involved in
Rich came back then right that was that
was just that was that was a that was a
what a time to be a live moment man you
know what I'm saying and like I said
earlier like
we're not knowing like we're really
creating history you know what I'm
saying we're not knowing that
we're going to change the game and
people are going to start doing
collaborative projects now you know and
this just come from two solo artists
collaborate collaborating on music every
day and it was London on the track it
was handling a lot of that production uh
yeah London on a trip you had done deal
um we had a lot of just a lot of Atlanta
uh a lot of Atlanta producers but London
was Hands-On
um that deal was on his own as well but
it's just us in the studio for three
months straight and like bro what are we
gonna do with the music when you guys
would decide you and Thug would decide
like
how would y'all decide who would take
the lead on like laying a hook down like
on like let's say lifestyle okay so
lifestyle so like for one like man man
though we'll be in the studio but we
would always be in separate rooms so
it's almost like uh we've always been we
would get a big enough Studio because
we're still
um solo artists and they're like I don't
want to interject on your creativity as
well as mine so well so lifestyle was
brought upon
um
first day I met Birdman
um we did a show down in Miami came out
to the show and I had just busted my
face in the walkthrough video from
dehydration there but like he fell out
he's on drugs but I was just dehydrated
you got a thing this 2014 I'm doing so
many shows I'm not getting no proper
rest and I didn't know you were getting
all the back end yeah I didn't know
about getting tired I didn't know I
didn't know I can fall out if I don't
get enough sleep you know what I'm
saying so I end up busting my face but
like two weeks after I brushed my face
I got a big offer in Miami you know I
ain't missing this money right put some
makeup on this [ __ ] so put makeup on it
but Birdman comes out to the show that
night Birdman come out to the show and
meet Birdman but Thug had already met
him and Thug had already been working in
Atlanta you know what I'm saying
what up nephew I think you should come
to the studio
they burned to see a bird you know what
I'm
saying
he signed with the Hawaiian be with they
have my mind thinking but that's they
probably go to the studio because my dad
came out to the club tonight right I
probably go to the studio we go to the
studio you know what I'm saying we're
not smoking water water
it was like uh you want to get in the
studio you feel like rapping I was like
hell yeah
play me some Beats
his baseball
you play lifestyle
but when I first heard it like
I was like I thought it was why I love
my dad like that way
you know I know there's stuff like boy
this [ __ ] thought was crazy crazy so
then it was like it's a versatile going
I did the first part like 15 minutes
laid it down laid it down I heard it was
on the radio two weeks later
radio two weeks later it was kind of
like a perfect mixture of like your Buzz
was crazy you had hit records already
Doug was bubbling yeah what's going on
you know what I'm saying but you guys
coming together it was like it was just
something crazy and then with the
Birdman approval yeah and it was you
know I mean like it was being young all
right I wouldn't like who was supposed
to go through what we went through even
like we were supposed to like that
moment was supposed to happen yeah you
know I mean it wasn't forced yeah you
can hear it in the music like you know I
mean after life so after lifestyle
that's when we decided like man y'all
boys got to be in the studio every day
right then we'll just come out come out
and put the project out you